then taking that knowledge and applying
it to many many others in different ways
to have them perform at their highest
so they can be real successful and that
group of individuals
become team members and because of their
individual great performances great
historic
teams and family performances are the
results
proof is in the results
and the proof is here today my immediate
family of 23 who are all
right here led by my wife kathy of 46
years
they are living it and because of this
they all have better chances of success
they are witnessing this historic moment
of someone quite ordinary
mostly going to the highest level as an
athlete and then
helping others do the same through the
professional level of coaching
did so for years showing others that are
just watching
reading or listening who really strive
to do the same
it works it works
living proof right there for those that
couldn't be here because of limitations
or have passed especially my mother
kate my dad mac my sister diane whom he
referenced was murdered in our own home
as a teenager because she fought for her
life
and didn't give in i know they are here
and they're all proud i thank you very
much for giving this
kid here the opportunity to reach this
level of the highest
award a civilian can get the
presidential medal of freedom
and of course for all those that push
the authority president donald j trump
i thank you for that including his
family
because yes i know this family has
wrestled
on and off the mat every day
and to the sport of wrestling being the
first to win this award
it becomes a higher challenge to all
that participate
by the way wrestling isn't for everyone
but it should be and now females
are strongly participating across the
world
i'm so honored to be here three minutes
what they gave me maybe
a little overtime not much
remember i've never left
practice as an athlete
or a coach when it was over
either thank you
[Applause]
congratulations
danny mac gable is one of the greatest
collegiate athletes and coaches of the
20th century
as a wrestler he was a three-time
all-american winning two
ncaa national championships and a gold
medal at the 1972 olympic games
he followed his career on the mat with
an even more celebrated coaching career
at the university of iowa leading the
hawkeyes to 21
big 10 championships and 15 national
championships
the united states is proud to honor
danny mac gable
for his remarkable contributions to
sports world and to our great american
story
[Applause]
and thank you for doing such a great job
we appreciate it
we aren't done yet
do you have any questions uh for dan
uh you know so many times
college wrestling isn't appreciated in a
way that other forms of wrestling
are uh do you feel that
uh this lifetime achievement award for
you
fully recognizes the sport of collegiate
wrestling
i look as it as a
inspiration and that others will have
something
that's beyond just winning on the mat
that they'll be able to uh want to do
something
like this and so it'll enhance our sport
because it isn't just like right now me
and him wrestling and
whoever wins the match gets a medal it's
more than that and that's opens the door
right now
for a lot of people
how does it feel one time the one time i
didn't focus
on what i needed to do i lost so you
have to ask all them
i don't know where am i
well we're very proud of you dan thank
you very much thank you very much
everybody
question mr president so
rudy is doing well i just spoke to him
he's doing very well
no temperature and uh he actually called
me early this morning he was the first
call i got now he's doing very well
that's another champion
greatest mayor in the history of new
york and what he's doing now is more
important
and he will admit that he was the
greatest mayor did a fantastic job
especially when
you see what's going on nowadays then
rudy giuliani was a great great
uh mayor and what he's doing now and he
will say it is even more important
a week from now mr president the
electors will meet to cast their vote
there's not a lot of time between now
and then to make your case to overturn
the vote
at this point are you looking to change
the outcome of the election
or try to make a case the american
people that it wasn't fair well i think
the
case has already been made if you look
at the polls it was a rigged election
you look at the different states the
election was totally rigged
uh it's a disgrace to our country it's
like a third world country these ballots
pouring in from everywhere using
machinery that
nobody knows ownership nobody knows
anything about they have
uh glitches as they call them glitches
religious weren't glitches they got
caught
sending out thousands of votes all
against
me by the way you know this was like
from a third world nation and i think
the case has been made
and now we find out what we can do about
it but you'll see a lot of big things
happening over the next couple of days
and i very importantly we're here for a
different reason we're here to
present our highest board our highest
achievement really something that that
really speaks to
such incredible achievement to a man who
really is a great man
and a great figure in sports not just
wrestling in sports
one of our greatest athletes of all time
and i just want to say
it's an honor to be with you thank you
thank you very much
thank you everybody appreciate it
mr president one more question about the
inauguration
congratulations sir he's gone
[Music]
congratulations